last week dr oz announced his candidacy
for the u.s senate from the state of
pennsylvania outlining his vision for an
america first make america great again
agenda and of course that immediately
prompted scorn and attacks from the
media mob very predictable you know
daring to question their far left
orthodoxy just listen for example to the
smears from that hard-hitting news show
on abc called the view take a look
what happened to him
what happened to him he's gone over to
the dark side
he said this
i tell you schools are a very appetizing
opportunity i just saw a nice piece in
the landsat which is a medical journal
arguing that the opening of schools may
only cost us two to three percent in
terms of total mortality and he was
arguing that we should open up schools
and and my thought was so you're willing
to sacrifice the lives of our children
yeah was was he willing to sacrifice the
lives of his children and his
grandchildren and that's when right and
that and that's when i saw
that's when i saw the turn in him here
with reaction republican senate
candidate for the commonwealth of
pennsylvania emmy award-winning tv host
dr oz is with us all right i thought
we'd do this a little differently
tonight we'll do kind of like a uh a
rapid round for people
i i noticed you answered the question
about your connections to pennsylvania
you were attacked on that uh there are
people all over the internet saying your
anti-second amendment is that true
no i'm strongly pro-second amendment
i've got my carry conceal i i own guns
and i think everyone should have a right
to bear arms is in the constitution but
can i say one thing before the rapid
fire yeah i want to say this last week
has been absolutely life-changing and
millions of video views on
doctorales.com which i think people
ought to follow lots of action there
overwhelming calls from voters liking
our message i'm going to come back to
that because of what the comments were
offered on the view and other outlets i
traveled to christmas markets to to
visit with county republican leaders the
campaign has made me so much more
confident than it already was about
america's future and these great ideas
they're going to empower us to fix
health care and education and the
economy and i gotta say what the
specific things that we've been exposed
to i have changed my views because i
realize that innovation and capitalism
work we can cut costs and save lives and
i'll tell you the hippocratic oath sean
you know is we always put our patients
first if i can be your public servant
for the people of pennsylvania i will
put voters first that's where they
haven't been in a while where do you
stand on education and because i think
if if kids don't get a good education
basically you're ripping out the rungs
of the latter to success in in life
is can we do better than what we're
doing now i don't think we could do much
worse
can do lots better and parents are
worried about education because every
parent wants their child to outperform
then yet we've got schools which
offer values to kids that don't align
with what the parents want and parents
can't use the usual private sector
solutions they don't have school choice
they don't have charter schools that
they can take their kids to and charter
schools cost less provide better quality
education and ought to be part of the
the puzzle but here's the biggest issue
at all it ought to be dealt with at the
local level and too often parents don't
have any voice they can't get their
schools to respond because they're
controlled at a much further distance
than just the local school
playground let's go a little quicker
defund dismantle nobel laws in cities we
see these you know robberies now every
single night your reaction what's the
answer
the answer is you you have high quality
police officers we need law enforcement
it's not working this city where i am
right now had its 501st murder last week
of a college student the person who
murdered him had actually been picked up
earlier for a carjacking but was
released this is the kind of stuff that
drives people
understandably
crazy but it also undermines the very
sanctity of our society which is safety
we need that
let's talk about abortion hot topic
issue we just had a case in mississippi
argued before the supreme court last
week it might change the viability from
23 weeks to 15 weeks
it might send
abortion laws back to the states your
thoughts
i'm pro-life with the three possible
exceptions of the mother's life rape and
incest that's how i stand yeah which is
a pretty common position for many in
pennsylvania let's talk a little bit
about immigration you talked about in
your announcement that your parents came
to this country legally we see what's
happening at the border your what would
the answer be for dr oz
i think what the prior administration
did was very wise you don't let
immigrants across the border that sends
a message to cartels to stop human
trafficking and also opiate trafficking
across the border which is what's going
on right now and because it succeeds the
cartels go back and get more folks to
bring them across the border
again the only way to prevent this
problem is to stop it at the point of
which these people are entering into our
nation what about the role of advising
consent and the type of justices you
would want to want on the u.s supreme
court and other judgeships
i think judges should follow the
constitution they should read it
carefully
and adjudicate
conflicts based on what the constitution
states we don't want to legislate from
the bench
how concerned are you about
the troops amassing on the border with
ukraine vladimir putin how concerned are
you about chinese fighter jets flying
over taiwan and china talking about
reunification how are you feeling about
lifting the sanctions to iran which joe
biden has done
all three are major concerns let's talk
about china for a second you know we
don't want taiwan compromise taiwan is a
major producer of vital products
including semiconductors but it's also
wrong this is a country that should have
its autonomy we want the same for uh the
ukraine we want the same for people
around iran the united states has been
there as a lone star as a north star for
many of these countries we need our
country to be strong so people can look
to us for leadership
why would dr oz give up i don't know
what your salary is but you have a
successful daytime syndicated show
i would
probably guess millions and millions of
dollars
to get into this i call it an adam shift
show i say it affectionately
why would you enter the world of
politics where by every definition it's
a blood sport and and you know you're
going to take the slings and arrows why
because i love my country i want to
serve this nation i witnessed what
happened during covet which i thought
was reprehensible politicians didn't
know what to do barked out draconian
orders that they thought would make us
safer but they didn't they closed parks
we can do better and the ladies of the
view if i can offer one big challenge
here we should be able to speak our mind
openly and if truly you're going to live
up to the name of the show please do
that understand why i'm doing this why
would i give it up i'm not going to the
dark side i'm actually having
conservative values because they mean a
lot to me i love our country all right
dr oz we're going to follow this race it
is a crucial senate race thank you for
being with us hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else